[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Serien schönen guten Abend an
diesem Dienstag alles wichtige in den
nächsten 20 Minuten und sportliches mit
Katja gehört dazu selbstverständlich
schönen guten Abend und hier schauen wir
jetzt auf die Themen
Signal an den Westen russlands Präsident
Putin und Chinas staatschefski wollen
wirtschaftlich noch enger
zusammenarbeiten
hohe Temperaturen und extrem viel Sonne
die negativen Folgen des Klimawandels
werden laut Deutschem Wetterdienst immer
deutlicher spürbar
Ausnahme für efuels im Streit über das
verbrennerausschlägt die EU-Kommission
einen Kompromiss vor Verkehrsminister
Wissing reicht der bisher offenbar nicht
aus
[Musik]
gespannt blicken viele auf Tag 2 des
Besuchs von Chinas staatschefski bei
Wladimir Putin nach dem Abzug vieler
westlicher Firmen und den Sanktionen ist
Moskau dringend auf pekingshilfe
angewiesen und die wurde heute einmal
mehr in Form von gemeinsamen Abkommen
zugesichert was Russland und China eint
ist ihr gemeinsamer Gegner die USA und
beide profitieren voneinander seit den
westlichen Sanktionen verkauft Russland
sein Öl und Gas nicht mehr nach Europa
sondern nach China Peking wiederum
liefert mehr waren etwa Maschinen nach
Russland und so ist der Handel um 30%
gestiegen über das gestärkte Band
zwischen Russland und China berichtet
jetzt Sebastian ihn
nur der Fluss Amur trennt China hier von
Russland in
lagaviationsstunden entfernt von Moskau
kommen sich die beiden Großmächte ganz
nah das merkt man auch auf den Straßen
die Chinesen verhalten sich uns
gegenüber immer korrekt die Qualität
ihrer wahren ist besser geworden weil
sie ihre Produktion besser organisiert
haben
was spricht denn dagegen ein starkes
Land zum Freund zu haben
das ist auch Vladimir Putins Meinung und
so empfängt er seinen chinesischen
Amtskollegen heute Nachmittag mit viel
Pomp im Kreml die gewaltigen Flaggen
Sinnbild für die großen gemeinsamen
Pläne und die zählt Putin beim Start der
Verhandlungen auf
chinesischen Firmen wolle man den Platz
anbieten den westliche hinterlassen
hätten Russland sei in der Lage den
wachsenden Energiebedarf Chinas zu
decken und die Verhandlungen über den
Bau der gemeinsamen Gaspipeline Power
auf sibiria 2 sein fast abgeschlossen
china will mit seinem Wagen Ukraine
Friedensplan auf der Weltbühne
diplomatisch Punkten Putin allerdings
schieb den schwarzen Peter Richtung
Westen
wir gehen davon aus dass der chinesische
Friedensplan dazu beitragen kann die
Ukraine Krise friedlich zu lösen sofern
auch der Westen dazu bereit wäre
am Ende eines langen gesprächstages
unterschreiben Chi und Putin 2
Erklärungen China und Russland wollen
ihre Partnerschaft vertiefen und bis
2030 wirtschaftlich noch enger
zusammenarbeiten
wir gehen jetzt nach Moskau zu Christian
seinem Christian gestärkte
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen ja aber beide
Seiten wollten sich auch mit dem
Friedensplan auseinandersetzen was ist
daraus geworden
ja der Fokus lag hier heute voll auf
Intensivierung der wirtschaftlichen
Beziehungen das wurde in den Statements
von Ski und Putin ganz deutlich und der
chinesische Friedensplan ja der spielte
da nur eine untergeordnete Rolle Putin
lobte ihn zwar dass das eine gute
Grundlage sein könnte für mögliche
Friedensgespräche gab dann aber doch
direkt im Westen und Kiew wieder die
Schuld dass man dort nicht bereit dafür
sei und ich finde das zeigt noch mal
ganz deutlich und das wurde auch an
keiner Stelle erwähnt das Putin zu
irgendeiner Art von Zugeständnissen
bereit wäre ja und China hat das auch
noch mal ganz klar betont dass man in
diesem Konflikt eine neutrale Rolle
einnehmen will aber ich finde nach
dieser Intensivierung der Zusammenarbeit
und den Statements heute kann man das
spätestens jetzt doch sehr in Frage
stellen wer also gehofft hatte das von
Moskau ein Signal Richtung Frieden
ausgeht der wurde auf jeden Fall
enttäuscht danke schön nach Moskau
Christiansen
Bundesbildungsministerin stark Watzinger
besucht derzeit Taiwan das sorgt für
Verstimmungen zwischen China und
Deutschland Peking erklärte man lehne
den Zitat böswilligen Besuch entschieden
ab China betrachtet Taiwan als
abtrünnige Provinz in Taipei
unterzeichnete stark singer ein
Kooperationsabkommen im
Technologiebereich es ist das erste Mal
seit 26 Jahren ist ein deutsches
Regierungsmitglied Taiwan besucht
wie steht es beim Klimawandel gestern
hatten wir hier berichtet was Fachleute
weltweit befürchten heute hat der
Deutsche Wetterdienst das abgelaufene
Jahr hierzulande bilanziert und kurz
gesagt die Sonne die Schienen extrem
viel und insgesamt regnete es etwas zu
wenig und besonders auffällig die
Durchschnittstemperatur lag 2,3 Grad
über dem langjährigen Mittel eine
Erwärmung deutlich über dem globalen
Schnitt immerhin die damit
einhergehenden Wetter extreme wie etwa
Starkregen lassen sich zunehmend genauer
Vorhersagen Peter Theißen
wieder ein Rekordjahr in Deutschland
neben 2018 war 2022 das wärmste Jahr
seit Beginn der Wetteraufzeichnungen und
das sonnenreichste eine Folge große
Ernte ein Busen in der Landwirtschaft
und die Pegelstände großer Flüsse fielen
im Sommer so stark dass die Schifffahrt
vielerorts eingeschränkt werden musste
erst im Herbst regnete es wieder
ordentlich allerdings wir sehen schon
seit einigen Jahren sinkende
Grundwasserspiegel die sich auch in den
Wintermonaten nicht mehr so erholen wie
sie es sollten und wie es nötig wäre
gleichzeitig gibt es immer öfter
Starkregen das belegt jetzt die
Auswertung von Messdaten der letzten
Jahrzehnte das heißt also sehr warme
Jahre und auch eher trockene Jahre
schließen nicht aus dass dann eben auch
sehr viele dennoch sehr viele
starkregende Ereignisse auftreten
inzwischen können die Messstationen
starkregende Ereignisse viel besser
erfassen die Verknüpfung dieser
Informationen mit den Daten von
wetterradaren erlauben jetzt
Risikoanalysen für jeden Ort in
Deutschland ähnlich wie bei kann man das
auf einer Skala von 1 bis 12 abbilden um
kurzfristig zu warnen oder auch um
langfristig Vorkehrungen zu treffen also
Dimensionierung von Kanalnetzen für die
Kläranlagen
Talsperren wird alles was mit
Wasserwirtschaft zu tun hat und
natürlich auch nützlich in der
Städteplanung wenn es um den
Katastrophenschutz geht was ich damit
auch Überschwemmungsflächen dann auch
noch besser dimensionieren lassen schon
heute kosten die Folgen des Klimawandels
viel Geld so betrug der
Versicherungsschaden allein für die
Katastrophe im Aatal 8 Milliarden Euro
die Forscher raten dringend zu mehr
Klimaschutz und zur Anpassungen der
Infrastruktur denn der Klimawandel sorgt
schon jetzt immer öfter für extreme
Wetterlagen
ja kein Wunder die Folgen des
Klimawandels machen auch unseren Wäldern
zu schaffen vor allem Wetterextreme wie
Hitze und Trockenheit sowie
Borkenkäferbefall haben den Wald weiter
stark geschädigt laut aktuellen Wald
Zustandsbericht sind 80% der Bäume in
Deutschland krank experten schlagen
schon lange Alarm der Wald müsste
dringend umgebaut und aufgeforstet
werden um den fortschreitenden
Klimawandel etwas entgegen zu halten
sie wissen Umwelt und Klimaschutz
gehören zur dna-grüner Politik und die
wird gerade auf einer Klausur in Weimar
diskutiert was ist bedeutet Teil einer
3er Regierungskoalition zu sein bekommt
die Partei seit Monaten zu spüren ihre
kerninteressen werden bei
verschiedensten Gesetzesvorhaben
hauptsächlich vom Partner FDP torpediert
Stichwort Heizung berichtet
auf der Klausur der grünen
Bundestagsfraktion verteidigt Minister
Harbeck seinen Vorstoß ab nächstem Jahr
neue Gas und Ölheizungen zu verbieten
keiner müsste sich sorgen neue
Wärmepumpen sollen sozial gestaffelt
bezuschusst werden und die alten
Heizungen dürfe man ja behalten
wer Gasheizung hat oder Ölheizung hat
der darf sie weiter haben niemand geht
in den Keller und reist die raus wer
kaputte Ölheizung oder Gasheizung hat
der kann sie heile machen und zwar nicht
nur einmal sondern so lange wie es
irgendwie geht
Koalitionspartner FDP geht beim
heizungsverbot nicht mit genauso wenig
wie beim Vorhaben der Grünen den
Kohleausstieg auch in den ostdeutschen
Ländern acht Jahre früher als geplant
nämlich bis 2030 anzugehen sie
argumentieren das marktwirtschaftlich
bedingt durch den europäischen
Emissionszertifikate Handel sehr
wahrscheinlich auch so Schluss sein wird
vor 2030 mit der Kohle dann aber
ungeplant dann überraschend für die
Menschen und unser Versprechen ist lasst
uns das gemeinsam machen deutlich die
Kritik der Grünen an FDP und auch SPD
Klimaschutz dürfen nicht zum Kulturkampf
werden es kann aber nicht sein dass in
einer fortschrittskoalition nur einen
Koalitionspartner für den Fortschritt
verantwortlich ist und die anderen für
die Verhinderung von Fortschritt für
eine Bundestagswahl die
nachher die Politikerinnen und die
Politiker belohnt die am wenigsten
Probleme gelöst haben
ich glaube da haben wir eigentlich
keinen Bock drauf mit Blick auf den
Koalitionsausschuss am Sonntag machen
die Grünen Druck auf den Kanzler auch er
sei verantwortlich dass die Koalition
ihre Klimaschutzziele umsetzt
die Grünen die ärgern sich auch über die
Haltung von FDP Verkehrsminister Wissing
zum Verbrenner aus ab 2035 Wissing
blockiert ist auf EU-Ebene weil er
Ausnahmen für sogenannte e-fuels
verlangt also klimaneutrale aber in der
Herstellung energieintensive Kraftstoffe
inzwischen gegen die EU-Kommission mit
einem Kompromissvorschlag auf diese
Bedenken ein aber Volker Wissing reicht
das offenbar nicht aus Christian
hübscher
Volker Wissing hat Post aus Brüssel die
EU-Kommission bietet dem deutschen
Verkehrsminister an für synthetische
Kraftstoffe sogenannte e-fiols ab 2035
eine extra autokategorie einzuführen in
dem Papier heißt es solche CO2-neutralen
Verbrenner müssen so gebaut sein dass
sie mit keinem anderen Kraftstoff fahren
können wenn reguläres Benzin oder Diesel
eingefüllt wird muss das Auto dies
erkennen und darf nicht starten aber
kann man Autos tatsächlich so klug
machen dass sie merken ob sie
klimafreundlich betankt werden
Autoexperten sagen ja es braucht eine
gewisse Sensorik und eine Software die
dann erkennt dass tatsächlich efuels ja
getankt werden noch einfacher ist
einfach ein entsprechenden
Einfüllstutzen zu bauen der ist aber
dann nicht so Missbrauch sicher wie eine
Software doch Volker Wissing sagt NEIN
zu diesem eu-kompromiss die Gründe dafür
sind noch nicht bekannt dem ZDF schreibt
der Verkehrsminister wir sind an einer
schnellen Klärung interessiert die aber
belastbar und verbindlich sein muss das
prüfen wir gerade sorgfältig diese mit
Strom erzeugten synthetischen
Kraftstoffe sind längst nicht marktreif
gelten als ineffizient und teuer stand
heute für den Massenmarkt nicht geeignet
doch die FDP hält damit weiter das
eu-klimaschutzprogramm auf dieses
Theaterstück gehört jetzt mal
schnellstens beendet der Kollege Wissing
sollte überlegen wie viel Porzellan er
da in Brüssel zerschlagen will bis zum
EU-Gipfel am Donnerstag soll der
Konflikt um das Verbrenner aus endlich
gelöst sein heißt es aus Brüssel und
Berlin
ein Hin und Her Florian neuhahn in
Brüssel
Brüssel hat diesen Kompromissvorschlag
gemacht warum ist das Thema noch nicht
vom Tisch na weil die Lage doch relativ
komplex ist was Brüssel hier anbietet
ist gewissermaßen eine Hintertür für
e-fuels aber die könnte in der Folge vom
EU-Parlament noch einmal geschlossen
werden und das scheint dem FDP-geführten
Verkehrsministerium eben nicht
verbindlich genug die wollen eine
verbindliche Ausnahme für e-fuels auch
nach 2035 und sind dafür auch bereit
Europa politisch hier einigen Schaden an
der Glaubwürdigkeit Deutschlands in Kauf
zu nehmen beide Seiten wollen jetzt in
der Tat das Problem noch vor dem
EU-Gipfel am Donnerstag lösen wo es ihm
sonst zum Thema zum großen Streit Thema
werden könnte aber ich habe hier in
Brüssel heute niemanden gehört oder
getroffen der auf eine Einigung noch vor
Donnerstag eine Wette eingehen würde da
müssen also noch ein bisschen warten
vielen Dank Herr Professor Florian für
diese Schilderung seit Jahren
beschäftigt der dieselskandal ja die
Gerichte jetzt gibt es ein wichtiges
Urteil zu illegalen
abschalteinrichtungen der Europäische
Gerichtshof hat entschieden das Auto
Käufer einen Anspruch auf Schadensersatz
haben und damit senkt das Gericht die
Hürden für entsprechende Klagen die
Deutsche Umwelthilfe die bezeichnete das
Urteil als einen Meilenstein für
Verbraucher Einzelheiten hat jetzt Frank
Dieselfahrer wie Bernd rühlke fühlen
sich betrogen 2015 kaufte er einen neuen
Mercedes C250 vom Magic was er nicht
ahnte Mercedes aber auch viele andere
Autobauer haben eine Motorsteuerung
eingebaut die bei kühleren Temperaturen
die Abgasreinigung reduziert oder sogar
deaktiviert Rülke klagt ich habe geklagt
weil ich mich einfach getäuscht fühle
ich habe da ein schadstoffarmes Autor
erwartet und habe jetzt mitbekommen dass
das also nur Patient der Wahrheit
entspricht Bernd rühlke aber auch viele
andere Dieselfahrer können durch das
heutige EuGH-Urteil künftig leichter
Schadensersatz vom Hersteller verlangen
wenn eine illegale abschalteinrichtung
vorliegt denn
abschalteinrichtungen sollen nicht nur
die Umwelt schützen sondern im Rahmen
der kfz-typ zulassungsregeln auch den
einzelnen Käufer inwieweit sich der
Käufer die bisherige Nutzung des Wagens
beim Schadensersatz anrechnen lassen
muss das müssen jetzt deutsche Gerichte
im Einzelfall entscheiden
mit neuen Chancen vor Gericht das heißt
wenn sie auch viele Kilometer gefahren
sind werden sie am Ende immer noch einen
Schadensersatz bekommen ein wichtiges
Urteil heute aus Luxemburg für Bernd
Rülke und alle anderen Betroffenen
Dieselfahrer
jetzt schauen wir auf den rentenstreik
in Frankreich zwei misstrauensanträge
hat die Regierung überstanden und damit
die Rentenreform durchgesetzt aber die
Proteste dagegen die gehen weiter
vergangene Nacht wurde bei
Ausschreitungen in Paris ordentlich
Krawall gemacht Menschen wurden verletzt
die Polizei in haben über 200
Demonstranten fest Widerstand auch an
den Raffinerien und Treibstoffdepots
beim Benzin kommt zu ersten Engpässen
Präsident macron will sich morgen im
Fernsehen an die Nation wenden
ein schweres Erdbeben hat den Norden
Afghanistans erschüttert das hatte eine
Stärke von mindestens 6,5 Angaben über
Tote und Verletzte gibt es noch nicht
das Beben wurde im Hindukusch
registriertem Grenzgebiet von
Afghanistan Pakistan und Tadschikistan
die Ausläufer des Lebens waren noch in
Neu Delhi spürbar
rassistisch sexistisch homophob so
beschreibt einen Untersuchungsbericht
die Londoner Polizei Mobbing Frauen
verachtende Rituale rassistische
Übergriffe innerhalb der Polizei nicht
nur in Einzelfällen sondern mit System
und allgemein würden die Polizisten
Gewalt gegen Mädchen und Frauen nicht
ernst genug nehmen aus London
Beamte der Metropolitan Police sie sind
im Großraum London für Sicherheit
zuständig doch schockierende Ergebnisse
des Untersuchungsberichts zeigen immer
wieder werden Beamte übergriffig
kriminell ja gefährlich keine
Einzelfälle sondern ein Problem in der
Organisation so die Verfasserin des
Berichts
gibt es eine Kultur der Diskriminierung
in der Metropolitan Police ich glaube
institutioneller Rassismus Sexismus und
institutionelle Frauenfeindlichkeit und
Homophobie gibt es quer durch die
Polizei presen
sie kann uns nicht versichern dass ihre
Beamten integer sind
Mörder ein Polizist er hatte ihr seinen
Ausweis gezeigt und sie aufgefordert
mitzukommen zwei Jahre ist das her ein
Schock und wochenlange Proteste vor
allem von Frauen danach wird die
Untersuchung in Auftrag gegeben sie
findet nicht nur Vergewaltiger unter den
Polizisten auch frauenfeinde homophobe
Beamte und Rassisten der Londoner
Polizei-Chef sollte längst aufräumen er
weiß zurück dass die ganze Organisation
als solche betroffen sein
Rassismus Frauenfeindlichkeit und
Homophobie in der Polizei auch dass es
System und Management Versagen gibt ich
verstehe in welcher Weise die
Untersuchung den Begriff institutionell
verwendet ich würde das so nicht tun
von einer Kultur der Diskriminierung
berichtet diese ehemalige
Kriminalkommissarin mit pakistanischem
Hintergrund
wenn ich den Raum verließ benutzten sie
abwertende rassistische Ausdrücke für
mich das erzählten mir Kollegen
das Entsetzen über die Fälle die der
Bericht enthüllt nicht nur in London
sondern quer durchs Land
die Preisträger für den renommierten
grimmepreis die wurden heute bekannt
gegeben allein sieben Auszeichnungen
gehen an das ZDF unter anderem anders
Historiendrama die Wannseekonferenz der
Film schildert wie nazi-funktionäre den
Massenmord an den Juden in Europa
organisierten in der Kategorie
Unterhaltung bekommen jan Böhmermann und
sein Team vom ZDF Magazin Royale erneut
so bereit für größeres ist auch ein
19-jähriger in der
Fußball-Nationalmannschaft Katja so
siehts aus viele geben ihm das Prädikat
hochbegabt und trotz seines
teenager-alters ist der kein Unbekannter
in der Nationalelf Florian Würtz ist
nach langer Verletzungspause zurück im
Team von Hansi Flick und könnte am
Samstag im Testspiel gegen Peru erstmals
in der Stadt elf stehen er ist ein
Gesicht das Neuanfangs das 19-jährige
Top-Talent soll eine Schlüsselrolle
einnehmen im fliegt-team Florian Würtz
gilt als große Hoffnungsträger mit Blick
auf die EM in 15 Monaten
ich habe auf jeden Fall Lust dabei zu
sein
vor allem auch er mit der Mannschaften
gutes Turnier zu spielen die Leute in
Deutschland einfach wieder zu begeistern
vor einem Jahr zog sich der Leverkusen
einen Kreuzbandriss zu verpassen die WM
nun sein Comeback im DFB-Team das Knie
sehr gut verheilt
wir haben in der Reha sehr gut
gearbeitet
ja und unser Ziel ja gut erreicht dass
das Knie einfach wieder hundertprozentig
ist 10 Monate lang ausgefallen nun soll
er zu einem Führungsspieler aufgebaut
werden und zusammen mit musealer bei der
EM das Herzstück der Offensive bilden
ja und der in der Fußball Champions
League der Frauen beginnt die Ko-Phase
die Viertelfinals stehen an und so
müssen die Wolfsburgerinnen morgen
leider ohne die verletzte Topspielerin
Lena Oberdorf auf den Rasen und in den
Hexenkessel bei Paris Saint-Germain
das Abschlusstraining gut gelaunter
wölfinen fand heute morgen noch in
Wolfsburg statt mit einer guten Portion
Rückenwind konnte Trainer Tommy Stroth
die letzten Informationen zum
französischen Meister Paris St Germain
an sein Team weitergeben Paris mit
vielen wieder der Qualität probiert auch
wirklich da ihre individuelle Qualität
immer wieder durchzubringen in Aktion zu
bringen da kommen wir doch viel viel
mehr über das Team seinem Team gelang am
Freitag ein klarer 5:0 Erfolg gegen
Turbine Potsdam mit zwei Toren der
herausragenden Alexandra Popp grund
genug also sich auf diese Dienstreise zu
freuen und auf den Park de brass im
südöstlichen vor Ort
heute Abend wird schon gespielt die
Frauen vom FC Bayern empfangen im FC
Arsen vielen Dank Katja zum Wetter so
viel es wird ungemütlicher Details
gleich von Österreich
mehr Analyse zum Russland China Gipfel
um 21:45 Uhr im heute journal mit
Christian Sievers ja das war schon
wieder von uns danke fürs zuschauen und
für Sie noch einen schönen Dienstagabend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter eine ganze Reihe
von Tiefs erreicht uns von Westen her ja
und die bringen Regen aber dazwischen
gibt es auch mal trockene Phasen
insgesamt ist es ungemütlich und es gibt
es gibt sogar Sturm dazu der kommende
Nacht erstmal noch nicht da gibt's vor
allem Regen im Osten der zieht
allmählich ab und von Südwesten her
lockertes auf die Temperaturen gehen
zurück bis auf zwei Grad am Alpenrand
und neun Grad Richtung Niederrhein
morgen dann erst einmal vor allem im
Süden Sonnenschein auch nach Norden ist
es trocken hier und da noch ein bisschen
Sonne und im Tagesverlauf nähern sich
hier kompakte Wolken mit Regen und der
Wind frisch dazu aus Südwest auf ja und
die Temperaturen die liegen bei 20 Grad
im Süden die höchsten Werte hier rechts
warm nach Osten sind immer noch 18 Grad
am kühlsten Richtung Schleswig-Holstein
bei 10 Grad die nächsten Tage weitere
Schauer und Gewitter mit im Gepäck vor
allem in der Nordhälfte ganz im Süden
eher sonnig noch am Donnerstag bei 11
bis 20 Grad dazu auch noch Gewitter
dabei am Freitag ebenfalls mit Gewittern
vor allem wird es dann auch stürmisch
nach Norden hin und auch am Samstag mit
Sturm ein schönen Abend